I spent the last four days in New York,
and now it's time to travel to Orange County to see my kids again.
Every work trip I go on,
I always take little whimsy Lou with me.
She's my little travel buddy,
and she's been doing so good on set
and running around New York for meetings.
Today we caught a flight from New York to Orange County,
where we'll be spending a little bit of time.
So I did my makeup and then packed up the rest of my bag.
I still haven't fully figured out how to pack a bag properly,
but we always make it work somehow.
At this point,
I was running a little late,
so I rushed out the door, and we headed to the airport.
Was about an hour drive,
but I love driving or walking through New York.
There's just something so magical about it.
Once we got to the airport,
we checked in our bags and headed through security,
and we actually made it perfectly on time to board the plane,
and before we know it,
we were in the air.
I always bring my journal with me pen,
and sometimes I bring a book.
But lately, I've been listening to audible quite a lot,
and I just started listening to Crescent City.
I also feel like I haven't watched a good movie in a long time,
so if you have recommendations,
let me know. We landed in LA,
and it felt so nostalgic being back here.
Before I got in the car
and we drove about an hour and a half down to Dana Point,
lucky couldn't wait any longer,
so he met us on the last fourth of our drive
to drive me back to the house himself.
I was so excited to see the kids at this point.
And when I got back,
they drew me pictures,
which was so freaking cute.
They were so excited to see me in whimsy again,
and they couldn't wait to take me down to the beach
and show me everything that they've been up to
and all the things they wanna do now that I'm here.